[Music]
Tom Holland and Zendaya Tom Holland
spinning a web over there Spider-Man Tom
Holland and Zendaya making all of our
swishes come true on their basketball
date night when we're not working we're
always together and uh and that makes a
really great chemistry that's the couple
at game two of the NBA playoffs for the
Los Angeles Lakers and Golden State
Warriors in San Francisco not far from
where Z grew up in Oakland oh this is
just like a culture you know and when
people from Oakland you feel it during
their date night the actress snacked on
popcorn while keeping her eyes on the
court Tom seemed laser focused too which
the analysts couldn't help but point out
Tom Holland and Zendaya Tom Holland
spinning a web over there Spider-Man
some suggest that Parker's powers
include the male spider's ability to
hypnotize females stop come on yes my
spider Lord
at one point Zeke got some Hometown love
on the Jumbotron
[Applause]
as for where Tom was well in eyewitness
tells E.T the actor got up before the
camera came by I'm really really lucky
to be in this position and uh I think
it's important for me to just sit back
relax and enjoy it but thankfully the
camera eventually found Tom which led to
this cute moment
the eyewitness adds that Tom and Zendaya
were in a suite and had so much fun both
were laughing through the entire game I
just feel very lucky this is Tom and Z's
second and rare public outing in a week
just days ago they hit up Usher's Las
Vegas residency where the Euphoria star
sang her heart out next to her boob
s
[Music]
it's great to have that support and that
love around you from Vegas to The Bay
you could say Tom and Z's date nights
are a slam dunk
oh
[Music]
foreign